combat chouih à la tuque qu'est ce que
c'est que l'acte c'est très simple je
vous posais des questions sur l'actu du
jour et pour pouvoir répondre vous devez
mettre un truc dans votre bouche mâché
et parler avec le tube bien là
exactement
alors attention je vous donne un point
uniquement si j'entends distinctement
votre réponse voilà je vous le dis
jean-michel donc amender n'aurait pas de
plongeon attention question on voit
toute l'actualité c'est la tuque
avant de répondre il faut manger un juge
merci qu'a dit eric zemmour au sujet de
laurent ruquier
alors autant y avait là je ne comprends
pas mais nagui cavale et le wii ware ou
quoi on peut voir que cela dit qu'il
était secteur pour moi pas bon bah oui
oui vous avez mangé qu'un morceau trop
tard merci que maintenant elle il a vu
qu'il était secteur il a dit qu'il était
secteur de la bd ce qui la gaule et
celui-là je crois vous gueulez oui il a
dit qu'il était sectaires dans une
réponse de bernard montiel et oui voilà
oui je vous le dis il a dit qu'il était
secteur interviewé sur notre stop people
tout le monde est interviewé sur europe
1 eric zemmour en a profité pour régler
ses comptes avec laurent ruquier eric
zemmour et et son ancien chroniqueur
avec qui il n'a plus aucun contact
il n'a pas mâché ses mots en ce qui
concerne son ancien patron regarder je
sentais entre ruquier barma à l'époque
cela près ça a changé
une grande une grande liberté une grande
de voiliers ils étaient ouverts ils
étaient pas il n'était pas devenu
sectaire ils le sont devenus après mais
peuvent trouver à oui oui par le suisse
laurent reuche et surtout je pense que
nous sommes en contact avec eux je veux
dire je n'ai pas du tout apprécié
ce qui ce qu'il m'a fait pour la sortie
de mon dernier livre où il m'avait
promis de m'inviter et où il a n'a pas
tenu sa parole
je vous trouve ça assez médiocres de sa
part surtout après ce que vous avez
rappelé que je crois avoir contribué un
petit peu au succès de cette émission
qui a duré 15 ans je crois que je suis
un peu pour quelque chose
bien sûr alors il a dit ça et il est
revenu aussi sur sa candidature
sa possible candidature aux élections
présidentielles va vous montrer ça dans
un instant qu'est ce que vous dites sur
eric zemmour elle a l'air énervé je suis
pas pour qu'eric zemmour en fait se
présente aux élections présidentielles
donc non mais ça c'est n'importe quoi
bien sûr bon ben alors on vend parlé
tout à l'heure de ça mais c'est sûr sur
laurent wauquiez non mais je comprends
qu'il soit amer parce que qu'on aime ou
qu'on n'aime pas zemmour effectivement
peut pas nier qu'il a participé au
thermique au début de de l'émission de
ruquier au succès de l'émission de
ruquier nous l'eau c'est un duo
emblématique et quand et camp rock et on
s'en souvient a taclé en disant je
regrette d'avoir pris zemmour je
comprends qu'il ait un peu mauvaise
ben oui c'était le meilleur attelage
naulleau zemmour et de loin honnêtement
ouais bon c'est sûr et naulleau naulleau
est exceptionnel
moi j'adorais aussi yann moix voilà
aujourd'hui je me suis jamais caché
d'ailleurs il ya surtout les deux
maintenant pour balances ton post
question on l'a entendu une minute de
zemmour il n'a pas dit de conneries
l'apady de tri faire insulte andrew et
ça passe il a raison quand il dit que il
a contribué au succès de l'émission au
début moi je suis d'accord avec jean
louis david haye l'a pas dit conneries
maintenant ils se sont tous raison quand
il dit que c'est un peu sectaire ce
serait qu'il ait mis son show que c'est
beaucoup gauchisé les invités sont de
plus en plus un peu bobo de gauche etc
et c'est pour ça que l'émission je pense
à comment ça je souhaitais surtout - non
mais je verrai cela laurent ruquier
entre nous jouons à laurent je pense
qu'il est passé complètement autre chose
il est sur les enfants de la télé avec
une très belle production est ce qu'il
est produit par endemol la même
production qu'à prendre ou à laisser et
mich pense que voilà il ses amis qu'il a
hissé ces salaires sont d'anciens
productrice catherine barma avec qui il
avait produit on a tout essayé avec qui
il a produit en date n'est pas couché et
c'est vrai que là je pense que l'on
requis il va vers de nouvelles aventures
il a envie de repartir sur autre chose
il s'est séparé donc je vous dise à son
ancienne productrice et là il va se
concentrer sur les grosses têtes sur les
enfants de la télé est peut-être sur le
samedi soir puisque apparemment
a priori garderie le samedi soir avec
peut-être les grosses têtes à la télé
voilà avec un producteur que j'adore en
plus qui est philippe il y est voilà que
j'aime beaucoup et qui est très bon donc
j'espère pour eux que ça va marcher oui
et il a eu vraiment raison d'arrêter
cette année pas faire la saison de trop
parce que d'errer cette année l'ancien
cette année la saison pro et laurence
cycle et laurent on est en convient mais
parfois je regarde l'émission je
connaissais aucun invité non mais c'est
donc à l'invité et puis c'était plus
l'émission qui faisait que tu as l'été
je vous dirais même loi rookie je pense
que cette année il l'a fait pour parce
que ils ont établi par rapport à sa
productrice et à france télévisions mais
je pense que pour lui c'était déjà
l'année trop ça la même l'année dernière
je pense qu'il ya deux années de trop
voilà qui l'a fait voilà pour au terme à
l'entente pas sa priorité cr v est long
à partir les grosses têtes et il adore
faire les enfants de la télé
s'amuse vraiment et puis survint qui
jubile je vous dirais que non plus mais
c'est pas ça on n'est pas couché je le
dis pour vous parce qu'on est une
émission vidéo je vous donne une petite
info laurent ruquier on n'est pas couché
ça lui a amené énormément de soucis sur
france télévisions les invités les
invités politiques les dérapages les
petites sorties
donc là il est dans un truc où il veut
faire qu du divertissement à mon avis il
a pas envie de rentrer dans le débat
social ou le débat politique
voilà laiseka dans les grosses têtes il
déconne rigole et ça c'est marrant il
s'éclate dont ils ont fait de la télé il
fait du divertissement et il veut
continuer à s'amarrer le samedi soir en
deuxième partie de soirée oui moi en
revanche qui serait bien c'est que
quelqu'un reprenne aussi un format comme
ça parce que moi ça m'allait bien dû au
début on est pas couché avec un invité
politique qui vient parler de la
situation du pays avec un mec qui
s'engagent balance son poste à valence
et à des gens qui viennent parler de
leur livre est alléchant qui vient de
sortir pour par ailleurs s'il ya la
deuxième par lambert avec avec eric nous
avons donc passé sociétal même emmené
par un truc mais non il ya des missions
dérives mais moi je n'ai jamais regardé
mais il respecte pas ses petits la
france et tous la même chose et ça va
peut-être manqué une émission sociétales
comme sa poche mais je crois qu'il
manquera pas bien quand je pense
qu'aujourd'hui je pense que tu n'as rien
à taper un bon je te le dis la vérité
moresmau tu sais que mon ami avant tout
et je pense que si les audiences de
laurent ruquier aussi ont dégringolé
c'est parce que j'en sais peut-être les
gens n'aiment pas ce qui est du format
comme rempli un peu gauche comme avait
dit quoi qu'on fasse on est haché si tu
ramènes un autre animateur avec un je ne
sais pas à trouver animateur puis au
cours de son interview a également donc
évoqué la possibilité de se présenter un
jour à l'élection présidentielle
regardez vous pourriez l'incarner vous
cette nouvelle droite
vous y avez pensé non j'ai pas ça vous
l'avez flore et l'esprit non il ya des
gens qui viennent et qui m'en parlent
qu'ils me disent tu me serais très
clairement est ce que vous me voilà oui
je vous dis moi je n'ai pas pensé moi
j'étais dans un rôle différent de
commentateurs d'observateurs etc mais
effectivement petit à petit jeu je
rentre c'est ce que je dis toujours je
suis pas un homme politique mais je fais
de la politique puisque je défend des
idées je mène un combat politique nous
avons rien jour vous présenter à une
élection présidentielle par exemple
celle et je vous dis les gens me posent
la question donc après on est obligé d'y
réfléchir avec eux c'est voilà comme ça
comme ça que je vais vous dire voilà
apparemment il va pas les dames c'est
pas étonnant le glissement on l'a vu
s'opérer régulièrement et petit à petit
entre le le journaliste au départ puis
le polémiste puis ensuite l'homme engagé
avec ses idées à lui 1 et le pas il
était nu il est élu non mais il reste
pas grand-chose à franchir bien sûr tu y
vas dans des conventions il a fait les
conventions et rennes et compagnie on
voit bien que il faut pas le pousser
beaucoup pour qu'il y aille
voilà moi je suis contre je peux me
permettre
oui bah merci je trouve que c'est
quelqu'un débatteurs comme ça doit
rester un débatteur ya que des coups à
prendre un politique on est quatre fois
moins lui ben on se trouve confronté aux
il a l'habitude on sera moins bien sûr
que non mais là là là là view il est
parti franchement il peut y aller on a
des convictions tu envie de défendre
l'animé c'est un fait imaginaire oui
c'est ça exactement aurélia qu'ils
voteraient pour lui
pas vous bah non nous ne voulons pas
voir des gens qui veulent couvrir du
nombre d'homicides et zéro point nommé
évidemment je suis je jamais d'accord
avec tout ce qu'il raconte mais c'est
quand même très intéressante attention à
ce qu'ils le discours est intéressant si
les cultes l'homme il est pas con non
les discours très intéressant mais
évidemment je suis pas alors ou d'accord
avec lui